si on imaginer un monde sans virus je
pense que le résultat immédiat
ça sera un des régulations à très haute
échelle sur tous les écosystèmes sur
terre avec des conséquences vraiment
difficile à imaginer des fois mais
surtout en temps de pandémie
on aimerait pouvoir rayer tous les virus
la surface de la planète
dans le contexte actuel c'est un petit
peu difficile de comprendre que les
virus sont sur terre à part nous rendent
malades et nous priver de coupe de
cheveux pendant quelques semaines
mon épouse bleus me couper les cheveux
mais si c'était pas le fait qu'on
connaîtrait même toit la vie sur la
terre c'est un peu paradoxal parce qu'un
virus tout seul tembo vivent un virus ça
sert à faire d'autres copies du virus
effet de se reproduire comme tous les
organismes un virus c'est quoi c'est
juste du code génétique qui est protégé
alors d'effacer protégé par une membrane
nettoie ses protégés par des protéines
mais ensuite c'est tout c'est vraiment
la base ils sont incapables de se
reproduire son un autre un salut l' on a
organisé dans laquelle ils sont capables
de se répliquer c'est pour ça que l'on
considère pas qu'ils sont vivants
on entend souvent dire qu'on a des gènes
de virus dont le génome est ce qu'on
serait différent si les virus existent
et peuvent absolument absolument et les
russes peuvent servir aux deux acteurs
de transmission des remèdes qu'ariel
génétique chez pas le chiffre précis
mais une bonne quantité de notre génome
c'est quelqu'un de björk qui se sont
intégrés dans notre génome je pense
qu'on devrait être reconnaissant envers
les virus ils ont joué un grand rôle de
distributrices à gênes au fil de
l'évolution
puis si c'était pas le temps
conviendrait mais beau monde la même
manière parce que des scientifiques y
ont découvert que le placenta des
mammifères il se forme et grâce à des
gènes viraux
il ya des personnes qui suggère une
origine de la vie virale fortement
débattu parce que justement le virus a
besoin dans notre donc la ferme la
question de la poule et l'oeuf
qu'est ce qui est arrivé avant
les virus très bénéfique aux écosystèmes
en terme de maintenir la diversité
si à un espace qui devient très très
abondants et virus pourrait servir à
l'abondance de cet espace là bon je sais
pas pour vous mais moi quand j'entends
ça c'est comme si les virus était sur la
terre pour punir les espèces qui
prennent le plus de place ça me donne
l'impression que c'est un peu ce qui est
en train de nous arriver
sauf que c'est possible de six chapitres
où nous dit au fond l'évolution aux
portes d'agen d'heure avec une liste
d'objectifs à atteindre les espèces
rappelé plusieurs rôles dans un
écosystème mais on peut vraiment d'autre
but que de se reproduire si vilain effet
que les espèces qui ont le plus de
succès c'est simplement parce que c'est
plus facile de se propager puis de se
reproduire au sein d'une espèce qui est
très populeuse et danse comme nous est
pas juste quand il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui habitent en un dans une
ville dans un hôpital dans n'importe
quel endroit et de transmission ici une
forme de vie que lundi la planète dans
son ensemble de manière généralement
assez dense et qui par tous ses biens
les bactéries et les bactéries et peut
vous êtes infectés par des virus
les virus qui préfèrent les bactéries
cellules animales ou végétales on les
appelle les bactériophages où les phages
pour les intimes pis les scientifiques y
en eiffage qui s'attaque aussi à nos
bactéries par exemple les fameuses
algues toxiques dans les lacs et ça
pourrait nous aider à assainir nos cours
d'eau les sages et les bactéries font
probablement le couple le plus vieux du
monde
un couple qui perpétuellement h 15 on ne
connaît pas un écosystème sur terre où
il y aurait des bactéries sont conviés
les sages c'est un bataille sans fin
entre les virus et leurs autoroutes et
je pense qu'on voit ça très bien dans
les interactions entre les bactéries et
les virus
parce que c'est une interaction qui dure
depuis des milliards d'années et on voit
quand même depuis trois milliards
d'années
y a pas de gagnant
c'est une bataille qui est tout s'est
fait de coopération et elle a même lu à
l'intérieur de nous parce qu'on est tous
un peu comme des écosystèmes ambulant
avec nos petites dit microbien intérieur
car certaines fonctions de ces de ces
bactéries qui sont dans notre système
digestif qu'on obtient grâce à cet âge
il ya d'eiffage qui sont très bons pour
nous dans le sens où ce seront des virus
qui vont infecter des bactéries
pathogènes celle qui nous rendent
malades
il ya des travaux récents qui ont
suggéré en fait que par exemple dans les
poumons ce eiffage qui sont là
naturellement présents pourraient même
servir de première ligne de défense
avant que le système immunitaire ne
s'enclenche parce qu'ils sont là parce
qu'ils sont dans le mucus de nos de nos
poumons et il reste la cee
ce serait ces phases là qui verrait en
premier les premières bactéries qui
débarquerait en tuant ses bactéries
pathogènes
il ya plein de molécules qui sont
produites dans le dans le mucus des
poumons qui du coup pourrait à l'air tel
système immunitaire beaucoup plus
rapidement mais ensuite il y à aussi
tous les autres fage qui infecte et
bactéries qui ne me rends pas malade et
des bactéries dont nous on a besoin en
fait pour produire des vitamines pour
digérer notre nourriture pour mettre en
place d'un système immunitaire
ces pages là ces virus qui infecte si
bonnes bactéries entre guillemets on
aimerait ne pas les avoir où on aimerait
pouvoir les contrôler nous savons que
les virus sont très très nombreux 10
puissance 30 le nombre de virus son art
c'est comme le nombre des toiles dans
l'univers c'est beaucoup beaucoup de
virus et beaucoup beaucoup de diversité
génétique
on est en train de gratter la surface de
cette diversité alors nombre est juste
incroyable
on en revient ce ratio ou sachant que la
majorité des virus qu'on connaît son
d'eiffage qui ne nous affecte pas dans
ce cas là nous on est plutôt tranquille
les virus de plantes aussi ne sont pas
connus pour nous infecté c'est aussi un
autre système dans l'application
donc nous
il faudrait juste juste s'inquiéter des
virus animaux et parmi tous ces virus
animaux s'inquiétait de ce qu'ils sont
capables de sauter d'espèces en espace
c'est encore moins fréquents ça arrive
de plus en plus parce qu on déstabilise
les écosystèmes et qu'on est en contact
avec des animaux
historiquement on n'a pas été en contact
avec eux mais dans l'absolu c'est une
fraction d'une fraction d'une fraction
donc oui on est aux ordres à s'inquiéter
juste une petite partie
[Musique]